how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe yesterday we got a
little bit of info
and a little bit of a spoiler about the
wanda vision series if you didn't catch
that video you can go check it out but
of course a lot of people were asking
when exactly are we going to be getting
the one division series
it has been confirmed that we are
supposed to get the one division series
this year and that has been confirmed by
disney however we are now into november
and we
don't really have any word yet on what
the exact date is
but yesterday disney and marvel did kind
of narrow it down for us
originally a big rumor was going around
that it was going to be released on
november 27th
and there was solid evidence behind this
last month people noticed that there was
a code on the disney plus site where
wanda vision was supposed to go
and if you looked into the code there
was actually a placeholder date
listing november 27th as the premiere
date for one division so for a while
we thought that november 27th is going
to be the release date however
every month disney plus releases a
trailer of all of the new projects shows
and movies that are going to be coming
to the platform
and yesterday they released their
so-called trailer for the whole month of
november
and unfortunately one division was not
on there we did see things like the
mandalorian and a brief look at marvel
616
docu-series that is coming to disney
plus as well but one division wasn't on
there which means that it's going to be
coming
in december considering the fact that
disney said it is coming this year and
it's not going to be coming in november
december is our only option however
there could still be a possibility that
the wanavision series could get released
in november they're simply not
announcing it with
mostly all of marvel studios projects
having to get pushed back
marvel and disney could simply be
playing it safe and not announcing that
it's coming in november even if it is
but just in case there's a problem and
they need to change something maybe
they're not going to announce it for
november however as of right
now i wouldn't exactly get your hopes up
as that same code that was on the disney
pluses website that said november 27th
has now been removed so what we're most
likely dealing with here is a december
release date for the one division series
which would be a great end to this year
we could end with the mandalorian the
start of the one division series and our
first look at spider-man 3 because let's
not forget a sony executive did say that
we would get our first
look at spider-man 3 by the end of this
year in december so unless the studios
are kind of just lying to us it should
be a good december and
end of the year which is much needed
after 2020. so it sucks that it's not
going to be coming in november but
december is only
one month away so only a month to wait
until the one division series so let me
know what you're excited about the most
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest news concerning one
division spider-man 3 and all of the
other mcu projects and i'm about to
start some holiday giveaways soon so be
sure to subscribe so you can enter in
those
as well for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof